تستمر لعبة اللوم في السودان حول
من المسؤول بالضبط عن هذه
الجولة الجديدة من العنف، حيث يلقي كل طرف اللوم على
الآخر في قلب هذا
الصراع على السلطة بين
أقوى جنرالين في السودان، الجنرال
البرهان هو زعيم
المجلس السيادي والقوات المسلحة السودانية.  زعيم البلاد
ومنافسه نائبه
المعروف أو الجنرال محمد حمدان تحدثت
معه وما زال يقول إنه ملتزم
بالسلام وملتزم بالعودة إلى
الحكم المدني في السودان، بل إنه
يعتذر لشعب السودان و
الأشخاص الذين يعيشون هناك
سفارا
[موسيقى]
أم [
موسيقى]
في محادثتنا يبدو أن الجنرال حامدي
يتوقع أن منافسه
الجنرال البرهان قد فقد السيطرة على
الجيش السوداني، على سبيل المثال قال
إنه على الرغم من التزامه
بوقف إطلاق النار المؤقت الذي توسطت فيه الأمم المتحدة، إلا أنهم كانوا كذلك.
يتعرضون لهجمات قناصة من
القوات المسلحة السودانية، وكان عليهم
الدفاع عن أنفسهم. ويقول الاتحاد الأفريقي
الآن إنه سيرسل بعثة ميدانية
إلى السودان لإشراك الأطراف المتحاربة
بعد أن عقد اجتماعا طارئا
لمجلس السلم والأمن التابع
لجامعة الدول العربية.  الأمم المتحدة والولايات المتحدة
وجميع الأطراف الإقليمية تطلب من
هذين الرجلين العودة إلى
طاولة المفاوضات للأمر بوقف إطلاق النار
والعودة والالتزام بهذا
الانتقال إلى الحكم المدني في السودان ولكن
حتى الآن لا تزال المواقف متشددة للغاية
نيروبي